okay so it seems like every few months a
new company someone comes out with the
new
fastest ever charging smartphone like
years ago the flagship iphone was
charging at five watts and that was
fairly standard it would take about two
and a half hours to charge the phone
from zero to a hundred then when the
pixel one came out that was super fast
charging at 18 watts then soon the
iphone bumped up to 20. then you might
remember one plus beat out everybody for
a couple years with 30 watts but soon we
had 45
65
80. now today right now this xiaomi 12
pro ships with this 120
watt charger this you could you can buy
this right now today it charges the
whole phone from zero to 100 in 17
minutes and then just a few weeks ago
oppo demoed this it's not on a real
smartphone yet but it would charge a
theoretical
240 watts which would go from zero to a
hundred
in nine minutes that's pretty ridiculous
and then as you may have noticed like i
have pretty much any time one of these
demos gets posted somewhere universally
the comments across the board are like i
don't want that on my phone that
definitely is going to overheat
good luck plugging that in for more than
five minutes before it explodes people
across the board are universally
convinced that there is no way that this
can be good for your smartphone's
battery which got me thinking
if this is true
then why would these companies keep
doing this
is fast charging actually ruining your
battery so i dove into it i just go
straight in plenty of google searches
plenty of articles read plenty of people
talk to and plenty of hot takes out
there but this is what i found so
batteries have improved in their
chemistry over time but right now all
phones use lithium ion or lithium
polymer batteries and the way they work
is they have a positive side and a
negative side and the lithium ions flow
from the negative to the positive side
through a liquid electrolyte solution
and as they flow energy is released into
the circuit that's what's keeping the
phone powered by the battery when that
flow is over though the battery has
reached zero percent and is dead so
charging the battery back up is moving
those ions back through from the
positive to the negative side through
that electrolyte solution so the first
thing to know about charging a battery
is batteries are kind of like a sponge
like they they absorb the most energy
when they have the least in them and
then as they get closer and closer to
full they can't absorb quite as
efficiently and then there is some
excess lost with a sponge it's just
extra water passing through with a
battery that's just excess heat and so
what that looks like is charging
actually happens on a curve those
numbers that you keep seeing with the
100 watts and 150 watt fast charging
that's not the constant rate of charging
that's just the peak the maximum that
they're capable of but that's typically
only briefly the actual rate so a 65
watt fast charger for example will
typically only hit 65 watts for the
first few minutes pretty early on in the
charge from low battery and then taper
off and basically only trickle charge at
a lower wattage after around 80 and you
can actually view that if you get one of
these incredibly nerdy cables with the
display on it that lets you see exactly
how much power your phone is accepting
while you're charging i'll link one of
them below the like button but then the
second thing to know is batteries do
degrade over time the iphone as you've
probably seen lets you literally
visualize it shows you the percentage so
if you go to settings and battery and
battery health you can see your iphone's
degradation rating as a number from 1 to
100 so this 13 pro i've been using is
still good for 97 of the capacity it had
when i got it five months ago so why
does it go down is the real question
we're trying to answer and turns out
there are several things that degrade
batteries i mean these are they're picky
little things they're very energy dense
little storage units they don't like
being at 100 exactly they don't like
being at zero percent and they do
naturally degrade over time as they go
through charge cycles and the ions pass
through that electrolyte solution over
and over again slowly breaking it down
this is totally natural and can't really
be avoided as you charge the phone more
and more but the number one factor that
damages batteries that degrades them
faster than normal but ruins your
battery is heat so the ions are moving
through that electrolyte a lot but you
can think of the electrolyte basically
like salts so they can be pretty
sensitive to changes in heat they can
actually crystallize and clog up the
anodes and cathodes which stops them
from being able to store the lithium
ions and like i mentioned earlier when
the battery isn't in the optimal state
of charge it's less efficient and that
extra runoff energy manifests as heat
the heat is no good so clearly the goal
here is to minimize any excess heat
around that battery which would damage
it faster than normal now the thing is
generally the more wattage the more
power you're pumping into this battery
the more heat it's going to generate so
it sounds like this extra fast charging
is clearly bad for your phone it's more
heat generated and it's bad degradation
but that's not something these companies
aren't thinking about so over the years
a bunch of these different smartphone
companies have basically been working on
trying to figure out how to charge these
phones as fast as possible without
generating any extra heat like if you
look at just xiaomi's page for their
fast charging alone there's tons of
charts and graphs and claims about what
they're doing to get around this so one
new advancement came from one plus when
they dropped that warp charge 30t
charger it was kind of interesting and a
little confusing maybe that we had warp
charge 30 and warp charge 30t and both
were 30 watts but 30t was faster but
this is because with 30t the power
management got handled in the brick
instead of in the phone so there was
more heat produced by the brick in the
wall instead of on the phone near the
battery so oneplus could put the same
amount of power into the phone but for a
longer period of time without heating it
up as much and so the charging curve
could be improved like this so that's a
nice step the downside there is we're
now we're getting larger power bricks
but that's a bit of a trade-off people
are willing to make i guess but then
another way we've seen a bunch of
companies jump on especially lately is
with something called parallel charging
so basically instead of putting a ton of
power into a single battery they
actually split up the battery into two
cells next to each other and then add
power management hardware to split the
incoming power this is a simple but
brilliant way to get faster charging
times without a ton of heat imagine
instead of trying to pump 50 watts into
a single 5000 milliamp hour battery just
doing 25 watts into two batteries of
half the size that's going to generate
way less heat it's only 25 watts but
combined when you draw the curves you
can achieve the equivalent of 50 watt
charging and you get to put 50 watts on
the box but it's with way less heat but
again there's a downside to this method
too which is a slightly smaller overall
battery capacity because if you take the
same internal volume of two batteries
instead of one that means there's more
space taken up by the boundary between
the batteries and the housing and that
charging management hardware i mentioned
so you'll often end up with slightly
smaller overall batteries if they're
split like this and then of course
something we've seen in just about every
new phone coming out which doesn't
really have a downside is just adding
more
cooling hardware onto the phone itself
sometimes that's heat shields and vapor
chambers sometimes it's a whole fan but
specifically we're trying to get the
parts inside from getting too hot it
feels like every smartphone announcement
for the past two to three years has some
sort of section about cooling especially
gaming phones you're of course cooling
the system on a chip too
but the better the cooling system
overall the more power you can put into
the phone without it getting too hot so
the real question is
is it working
like is it is it that simple you can
just as long as you keep the phone cool
enough you can put as much power into it
as you want well there are the downsides
i mentioned earlier with the larger
brick and maybe the phone's got to be
thicker with more cooling and has a
smaller capacity battery
but the question we're trying to ask is
what counts as ruining your battery
that's a simple one and it turns out
there's actually an industry standard
for this so from the research i've done
and the people at these companies i've
talked to that generally accepted target
goal is 80
battery health after 800 charges
so let's say you charge your phone
roughly once a day that'll pan out to
about two years so 80 charge after two
years so this iphone now that i'm at 97
after about five months is on track to
be at roughly 85
after two years which that's pretty good
that's above the industry standard
officially not being ruined now for all
these super fast chargers that are new
well it's tough because they're new so
they've just come out and we don't have
long term data and it sucks that the
only information i can use is just
coming straight from those companies so
i'm basically taking their word for it
that yeah the fast charging doesn't ruin
the phone over time but it's the best
information we have
and it is actually surprisingly
impressive so from their test results
xiaomi on their site say that their 120
watt charging tech is rated to maintain
80 battery health after 800 charge
cycles
apple on their site they don't have the
fastest charging but they say 80
after just 500 charges but like i said
it seems like they're outperforming
their own claims hey under promise over
deliver and then oppo and oneplus who've
announced they'll have a 150 watt
charging phone this year
say that they've specifically stated
it'll go 80 battery health after 1
600 cycles so that will outperform the
industry standard which i guess means
they have room to keep going up now
don't get me wrong the trade-offs are
very real not everybody wants a thicker
phone or a larger power brick or a
slightly smaller capacity battery but
from where i'm sitting and from the test
results that we can go by
basically fast charging does not have to
ruin your battery life and really the
best part of that is just convenience on
top of the fact that these companies are
all actively still working on making
this stuff better you might have heard
about gallium nitride chargers there's a
couple actually out there already in the
market that allows the brick to actually
be much smaller than the typical silicon
charges we're all using now so you can
do a 65 watt gallium nitride charger
half the size and still put the same
power into the phone but really what it
comes down to these days is it's called
a smartphone for a reason batteries
these days
are smart like modern phones all have
tons of hardware and sensors inside the
phone to help measure temperature and
regulate charging so it's doing all
kinds of stuff automatically and then
the phones all will add a bunch of
software features on top to help you
actively maintain the battery to the nth
degree plus you know phones like the rog
phone 5 have pass-through charging so
when you're plugged in and gaming which
is typically not a good idea on a
regular phone it can just power the
system and it doesn't add charge to the
battery at all so you're not putting
extra stress and heat on the battery and
it can maintain battery health for a lot
longer the latest iphones and pixels too
right now have a feature where if you
plug in at night around the same time
every night after a few days it learns
when you wake up so instead of charging
right to 100 when you plug it in it
charges up to 80 then waits all the way
until you're about to wake up maybe an
hour before your alarm and then charges
the rest of the way up to 100 so you
wake up with a full battery but better
health and pretty much any other phone
with this super fast charging coming up
is gonna have to have a suite of battery
health options that you can mess with in
the software to take your battery health
protection to the next level so i don't
know how fast these phones charging is
gonna get in the next couple years
inevitably it's just gonna keep getting
better as companies work on it but what
i can tell you
is the best thing we can do for our
phones is to just
use them like normal and basically don't
give them any extra reason to get hot
you know leaving it in the dash of your
car on a sunny day
gaming while plugged in for long periods
of time stuff like that if you can avoid
your phone getting super hot you're
doing the best thing you can for your
battery and these smartphone companies
all know that battery problems are bad
news so if they're all doing their jobs
then we should all be good fun fact the
famous galaxy note 7 battery exploding
issue as crazy as it was it wasn't
actually due to fast charging or
overheating it was actually just them
with their battery supplier getting some
dimensions wrong and some bending going
on of the battery with the positive and
negative sides up in the corners
something to think about
either way now you have the answer
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one
peace